[Musique]
je marche sur le mien
un champ vert le rouge
une odeur comme dans bol d'air alpin
[Musique]
personne à la ronde
mais la roche derrière moi respire oui
elle respire nos morts des cadavres
enfouis dans sa main c'est dans ses
feuilles font respirer les parois de la
montagne le concept c'est un challenge
en fait c'est une charte très précise où
ça nous demande à un auteur ou une
autrice d'écrire un texte en trois mois
sur le thème de son choix mais qui doit
faire quoi l'actualité un texte qui fait
45 minutes une heure maximum pour quatre
acteurs actrices et que les en français
et ou en créole overview efect et c'est
un peu le la vue d'ensemble que nous
peut avoir de la terre qu'on est dans
l'espace et la vue d'ensemble sur notre
société aussi
les pommes d'amour les chichis
c'est énormément de stress et en même
temps c'est une pression hyper positive
parce qu'on est obligé d'être super
efficace pour rendre le texte avec sa
vraie valeur alors on a pu discuter un
peu avec l'auteur quand même et Lolita
nous dirige avec beaucoup de
bienveillance et de gentillesse c'est un
enjeu extraordinaire pour un comédien de
se dire waouh 5 jours ça y est on joue
c'est ouf regarde-le l'ordre faire sa
ronde avec l'idiote méchanceté d'un
petit colonel vexé à qui on obéit quand
même faute d'envie
en attendant faut prévoir ton
anniversaire
dans deux jours 9 heures et 34 secondes
c'est un défi incroyable c'est surtout
les univers différents qui se
rencontrent les improvisateurs et les
comédiens le dictateur gymena avec un
texte Isabelle Martinez ces deux univers
différents et puis nous voilà c'est
juste incroyable de pouvoir travailler
avec des gens voilà qu'on ne doit pas
tous les jours
le placard à balais
vous voulez savoir
souris quand tu dis non le placard
quand même tous les jours généralement
l'actualité le plus tôt négative en plus
donc nous subissons et c'est nous on
essaye à notre façon artistiquement de
montrer comment l'écriture dramatique ou
même le théâtre il peut en parler de
l'actualité donc l'actualité c'est un
sujet concerne tout le monde au-delà de
des rangs sociaux mais les dires mais de
toute catégorie il concerne tout le
monde il concerne à nous et comment
l'art dramatique il peut prendre ça
l'actualité interroger Natalia distance
que nous peut rien de ça ne peut plus
rien que le peu cause dessus pour pas
subir
[Musique]